train enthusiasts couldn't wait for this
moment the return of a train that takes
you to Brussels or Berlin while you
sleep in many ways it's much more
comfortable because you don't have to go
through security you don't have you have
your privacy but you can open the window
looking out it's just much more human
traveling on a train you meet
interesting people and you get people
wanting to speak to you no one speaks to
you on the plane since flying became the
cheaper and faster option most overnight
trains have disappeared now Europe is
experiencing what some have called a
rail Renaissance besides the new sleeper
train between Berlin and Brussels
through Amsterdam there's also a night
train from Berlin to Stockholm which
started operating earlier this year the
overnight Journey from Stuttgart to
riyaka in Croatia was launched December
2022 together with the service from
Prague to Zurich in Switzerland and
night train from Paris to Vienna started
in 2021
going to sleep somewhere in Germany and
waking up in Amsterdam or Brussels can
be a fun and efficient way of traveling
while emitting less CO2 at the same time
but traveling internationally by train
in Europe is still quite a challenge
because when it comes to trains borders
still very much exists within the EU
when Chris engelsman tried to revive the
European sleeper line different rail
systems between countries was only one
of his problems the railways and also
the infrastructure managers are
organized very nationally so they have
their own rules and and we are a
European Railway and we want to have
international trains running and for
most Railways that is just a smart small
part of their work and their thinking
statistics show traveling by trains
emits at least 10 times less CO2 than
the same distance by plane still until
recently only eight percent of Passenger
travel within the EU plus by train going
by plane is often cheaper due to
International train tickets being taxed
while plane tickets and fuel are
tax-free but some say operators can do a
lot more to promote long-distance trains
they all need to work together
but if we want to find a new balance we
need to work and think European if we
would use all the infrastructure we have
for international lines in a better way
it should be possible to have much more
frequent train services
10 hours after leaving Berlin the
sleeper train is arriving in Amsterdam
20 minutes later then scheduled because
of Maintenance work on its aging
infrastructure one more challenge the
new sleeper train will have to deal with
step fast and Al Jazeera Amsterdam
foreign